the first time house in Petrie and
investigators are hearing testimony from
someone who was actually on the call
between President Trump and Ukraine's
president his name is Lieutenant Colonel
Alexander ven Minton he's a White
House's top national security expert on
Ukraine in just a few hours it's
scheduled to begin at 9:30 he will
testify to lawmakers that he told his
superiors twice that military aid was
being improperly tied to politics
this morning's interview comes two days
before House Speaker Nancy Pelosi plans
to hold the first formal vote on the
impeachment inquiry Nancy Cordes is on
Capitol Hill Nancy why is Vinh man's
testimony so significant well because he
is the first current White House
official to testify and because he is
saying in his opening statement that he
found the president's actions improper
and that he even went to White House
lawyers this summer to warn that mr.
Trump had asked his Ukrainian
counterpart to investigate a campaign
rival Alexander vind Minh is an Iraq war
veteran who oversees Ukraine policy at
the National Security Council
he'll tell congressional investigators
today that he grew concerned after
listening in on the president's July
phone call I did not think it was proper
to demand that a foreign government
investigate a u.s. citizen the request
to investigate Biden and his son had
nothing to do with national security he
says adding that he warned NS seize lead
counsel that such a partisan play would
undoubtedly result in Ukraine losing the
bipartisan support it has thus far
maintained this would all undermine US
national security there was no anything
there was no pressure put on him
no anything the president continues to
deny that he withheld military aid and a
coveted meeting in an attempt to extract
those promises but the evidence to the
contrary is piling up House Democrats
will introduce a resolution this week
laying out procedures for public
hearings and outlining due process
rights for the president and his council
the resolution will set forth procedures
that the committee will use but
Republican
who had pushed for such a vote slammed
the decision I strongly oppose any
attempt to legitimize this soviet-style
impeachment process and the White House
says it may not cooperate even if the
resolution passes it just proves our
point that this that this was
illegitimate and they'll concede it from
the beginning
Nancy House Speaker Pelosi sent a letter
to her Democratic colleagues announcing
this new resolution what's behind that
move well she says that this is just
meant to lay out procedures for the next
phase in this impeachment inquiry that
she's not bowing to GOP pressure to hold
a vote but at the same time Anthony
here's how she describes the vote she
says quote it should eliminate any doubt
as to whether the Trump administration
may withhold documents prevent witness
testimony or continue obstructing the
House of Representatives the White House
demanded this vote but now aides tell us
they are not going to decide whether to
cooperate until they get to see whether
the president is granted all the due
prices process rights that they've been
demanding including the right to call
and cross examine their own witnesses
Nancy Cordes of the Capitol thanks Nancy